- Whose fuckin' permission
are you looking for?
Go do your thing.
You're gonna die.
(hip-hop beat)
("At Last" by Blake Savage)
- [Uber Driver] So just let me know
where would you like to be dropped off at.
Somewhere over here--
- [Kyle] It's around here.
I think it's like some sort of cafe.
Let me check.
- [Uber Driver] Yeah, Telegraph Cafè.
Thank you, have a good day.
- [Kyle] Thanks man, you as well.
("Halation" by Thoughts Awaken Us)
- What up guys.
Quick little video on
something that has been
dinging my phone left and right
in the DM, email, and tweets
and I'm just frustrated AKA optimistic
that this may be the video that
changes your mindset.
Just a quick little rant.
It's called Fuckin' Permission.
Like who the hell's permission
are you looking for to do your thing?
Like who is this person?
Is it your mom?
Is it society?
Is it your partner?
Is it the people that are
commenting in your social media?
Is it something that happened
to you when you were nine?
What permission are you looking for?
I'm just so tired of you know,
so many people are using me right now
to give them permission to do stuff
that it is my literally,
my literally greatest feeling of my life.
The feeling that I, through my content
every day on Instagram or my podcast,
am giving you permission to win
excites the shit out of me.
But my friends, and I
can't even like contain it,
very simply, like, can
you answer this for me?
Whose fuckin' permission
are you looking for?
Go do your thing.
You're gonna die.
It's going to end.
Something bad is gonna happen.
Something great is gonna happen.
But most of all, nothing's gonna happen
unless you do something.
Please stop looking for permission.
Please go do that thing you wanted to do.
Ask that person out.
Start that company.
Quit that fuckin' bullshit job.
You can always get another bullshit job.
Stop asking for permission.
Make the end of this year the moment
that you finally make 2018 the year
when you start living your fuckin' life.
("Jester" by Clowns)
Hey, live from the streets of New York.
Hey vlog, I know today's gonna be
a little bit of a short episode.
I was even taking my mic off
hence why I'm holding it,
but you're about to
see me walk into WeWork
and I thought, you know
between the rant I just did
which I'm sure will be in
there and some of the B-roll,
I'm sure Kyle will chop it up proper.
Obviously this is a day when
most of the world is traveling.
This is the Wednesday before Thanksgiving,
favorite day 'cause I love when the world
is shut out and shut down.
I feel like I'm productive 'cause you know
I hate when everybody's
working when I'm not
but I love working when
everybody else isn't.
Anyway, going into WeWork
I thought to extend
the vlog's quality here.
What WeWork tapped into is
just rethinking the world.
You know like, why do you have
to work in your home office?
Why do you have to work
and rent a five year lease?
They took advantage of a retail arbitrage
and a community and a brand
that a lot of people haven't
and so as I'm thinking about voice
and I'm thinking about virtual reality,
I'm thinking about AR and cryptocurrency.
You know, we've lived
through the search era.
We're in the midst of
the social content era
but for all you 20 year olds,
please start thinking
about the other trends.
Every industry is about to be disrupted.
Retail at an all-time
low here in New York.
As a matter of fact, back to WeWork,
they just took over the
Lord and Taylor building,
it hasn't happened yet but that's where
our headquarters is going.
Lord and Taylor are an iconic retail
that's been here for 100 years.
Point to Old Navy right now.
I'm gonna just make a
very simple prediction.
That Old Navy being there, right,
the likelihood of that in
seven years is quite low.
Why?
Because more of us are
buying on the internet.
Like why are we spending $6 on coffee
like this young lady just did at Fika?
It's $6 coffee.
$6 coffee.
Go tell your grandfather people
pay six bucks for coffee.
What are the next things?
Meditation.
Obsessed, thinks it's
gonna be a huge space.
Please use this short
episode and this rant as well
to rethink the game.
Why can an entrepreneur,
show your shoes Kyle.
Why can an entrepreneur
sell out of sneakers
in 11 hours and break a website?
I'm not a rapper, I'm not an athlete.
Oh, maybe it's 'cause entrepreneurship
is being put on a pedestal.
Maybe nerd culture is taking over.
All these things.
Cryptocurrency, self-driving cars, slime,
how-to videos, kids that
watch, we have three year olds
searching Youtube with their voice.
My friends, we are living
through the greatest era
of human and consumer trend shift ever.
Ever.
I was at a Knicks game the other night,
I bet you a bunch of you saw that content.
Kyle, chop in some of my Knicks video
that people put up on
Twitter, you'll find it.
- [Announcer] And loose out of bounds.
And the Knicks are coming
back, that's the 14th--
- I'm sitting next a 72
year old man wearing Yeezys.
72.
72 year old in 2018 is not the same as
a 72 year old in 1998.
The world has fuckin' changed.
Go out and get yours.
Be open.
Meet new people.
Say hello.
Ask questions.
Understand why people are
wearing backpacks, right.
Understand what this
world is doing right now.
This is our moment.
Go and fuckin' grab it.
("On The Way" by The Robbery)
(Bossa Nova beat)
(dramatic music)